el hasta hoy abogado de Pedro Castillo
El letrado Benja Espinosa no ha dado a
conocer mayores detalles que motivaron
su dimisión pero a través de medios
locales se señala que a la familia
presidencial no la habría gustado
absolutamente para nada que la fiscalía
haya allanado el palacio de gobierno y
que su abogado defensor no haya podido
salvarlos de esta situación crítica y
una aguda discusión se manifiesta habría
precipitado la dimisión de El señor
Benji Espinosa pero esta no habría sido
la única renuncia de la jornada esta
tarde También se conoció que el ex
canciller Manuel Rodríguez cuadros que
se desempeñaba como representante del
Perú ante la Organización de las
Naciones Unidas emitió y por otra parte
también
Fuentes diplomáticas se han afirmado que
el embajador haroldford que hasta hoy
el cargo de representante peruano ante
la organización de los Estados
Americanos también de emitió fuentes
diplomáticas manifiestan que ambos
Embajadores no están conformes con la
administración de Pedro Castillo nos
vemos ahora al caso de la cuñada de
castillo de qué se acusa a Jennifer
paredes y por qué la buscaban
a Jennifer paredes el acusa de ser mejor
dicho activar lo que se denomina acá
como tráfico de influencias hay unas
pruebas un vídeo que fue propagado por
algunos medios de comunicación donde se
le veía ella ofreciendo obras para un
pueblo en la región de cajamarca de
donde es oriundo del presidente Pedro
Castillo sucede que coincidentemente
tras descubrirse las visitas de el dueño
de una empresa al palacio de gobierno en
cinco oportunidades en dos ocasiones se
reunió con Jennifer paredes y en otras
tantas con su hermana Este empresario
habría ganado una licitación por unas
horas por más de un millón de dólares la
fiscalía sospecha que ella es partícipe
del delito de tráfico de influencias y
lavados de activos es por eso que se
estuvo buscando ayer precisamente se la
buscó el palacio de gobierno y no la
pudieron los equipos de la policía y de
la fiscalía fueron devorados una hora
para el ingreso al palacio presidencial
eso motivo en otras pesquisas que se
desarrollaron en la jornada en cajamarca
y esta tarde Jennifer paredes ha
entregado a la fiscalía ella va a ser
detenida por 15 días Entre 10 a 15 días
mientras duren los interrogatorios de la
fiscalía algunos juristas están
señalando que ella no le queda más que
contar toda la verdad porque los delitos
de tráfico e influencias y lavados de
activos son penados en Perú con una
cárcel de Entre 10 a 15 años de prisión